[Musik]
hier sind zwei
Geräte ich übertrage ein Dollar von dem
hier zu diesem
unmittelbar
den
Betrag und
senden wird
[Musik]
gesendet
fertig was hier zu sehen war wirkt auf
den ersten Blick wie eine normale
Transaktion Geld gelangt elektronisch
von einem Konto auf ein anderes
es wirkt wie eine banale Banküberweisung
ist aber die womöglich revolutionärste
Technologie die wir Zeit unseres Lebens
erblicken
werden diese Technologie heißt
Bitcoin Geld ermögl
denustausch und Dienstleistungen
zwischen vielen
Menschen Geld dient überall als
Tauschmedium Geld ist das hertstück
unserer Existenz wir handeln jeden Tag
miteinander aktuell Geschehen fast alle
unserer täglichen Transaktionen über
eine
Drittpartei Banken Kreditkartenfirmen
oder andere Zahlungsdienstleister
sie führen auch letztlich an unserer
Stelle die Transaktion
durch so war bis zur Erfindung von
Bitcoin bitcoin ist eine der wichtigsten
Erfindungen der Menschheitsgeschichte
und wird unser Leben massiv
verändern es klingt erstmal kompliziert
und schwierig zu
versteheningen er n D hör aber bitcoin
ist sogar einfacher als
Emails was also ist
Bitcoin zuerst sei gesagt es geht nicht
wirklich um
Münzen bitcoin ist eine neue Form von
Geld eine Währung die nur im Internet
existiert manche reden sogar von
magischem
internetgeld ein Teil der Verwirrung
fußt wohl darauf dass es zweierlei ist
eine Währung und auch ein
zahlungsnetzwerk etwas dass beides
zugleich ist gab es noch
nicht der Dollar ist eine Währung kein
zahlungsnetzwerk Paypal und Visa sind
zahlungsnetzwerke keine Währung bitcoin
ist beides
zugleich die Währung hat zudem die
Eigenschaft dass sie sofort überall hin
teleportiert werden kann einfach so fast
umsonst und niemand kann diese
teleportationen aufhalten niemand kann
sie abfangen und wenn man aufpasst geht
es sogar
anonym mit Bitcoin kann man auf
Knopfdruck jeden Menschen bezahlen oder
von jedem Menschen bezahlt
werden nach der globalen Finanzkrise
veröffentlichte ein Autor unter dem
Pseudonym Satoshi nakamoto ein
neunseitiges Dokument in einem
Onlineforum
das Dokument trug den Titel Bitcoin ein
elektronisches peertopeer Cash System
und legte den Grundstein für die erste
funktionierende Implementierung die
zentralen
Geldes das sind Tageskerzen von Bitcoin
mir geht es aber um diese Trendlinien
wie auch schon in anderen Vorträgen
heute ich fing 2007
bei Jahre vor dem Beginn der
Finanzkrise nach ging ich zu JP Morgan
und wurde
VP das war mein letzter Job sie alle
waren in der Innenstadt von
Manhattan ist ein Veteran der Wall
Street der ehemalige VP von JP Morgan
erforscht heute Bitcoin und gibt sein
Wissen angeneigte Zuhörer
weiter schwierig zu
erklären man muss es so einfach wie
möglich machen im Grunde genommen ist es
so wie eine einfache digitale Nachricht
zu
verschicken wir haben uns alle an
Computer gewöhnt versenden E-Mails
Bilder aber wir verschicken immer nur
Kopien wenn man auf Senden klickt behält
man immer die
Originalversion
beananstion auf senden und eine
vermittlerpartei verschiebt das Geld von
einem Konto zum anderen Bitcoin löst
dieses Problem obwohl es etwas digitales
ist wenn man senden drückt verschickt
man keine
Kopie man verschickt ein echtes
digitales
Objekt im Grunde genommen ist Bitcoin
ein neues
Geldsystem es unterscheidet sich von
bisherigen Geldsystemen jed
dahingehend nicht an einen Ort gebunden
ist dieser dezentrale Aspekt der Bitcoin
Plattform ist ein Grund warum es so
einzigartig und revolutionär
[Musik]
ist wir alle kennen PayPal Visa und die
ganzen Banken diese altbekannten Dienste
entscheiden darüber wer ein Konto haben
darf wer mit wem und in welchem Land
austauschen
darf
bei Bitcoin gibt es niemanden der das
kontrollieren kann nur das
softwarepokoll für das jeder interaktive
Software programmieren kann die dann auf
dem Handy oder Computer installiert wird
mit deren Hilfe kann man dann mit jedem
auf der Welt interagieren der auch
Bitcoin Software
nutzt die Software des Bitcoin
Protokolls wird gemeinhin Wallet genannt
eine digitale Geldbörse die Bitcoins
Verw und B zwischens versenden
kann das Bitcoin Protokoll ist
quelloffen der Programmcode also
öffentlich verfügbar wodurch jeder
darauf aufbauen und ihn verbreiten kann
auf diese Weise können Programmierer dem
Bitcoin Netzwerk neue Funktionen und
Produkte hinzufügen ähnlich wie man dem
Internet neue Webseiten hinzufügen
[Musik]
kann Jason für ihn in Australien ist es
spät am Abend und wir machen seine erste
Bitcoin
Transaktion wir nutzen Skype damit alle
sehen können wie schnell und einfach das
geht ich drücke hier nur auf
Senden Jason tippt auf
anfordern wenn er das tut erscheint ein
QR Code mitten auf seinem
Bildschirm den hält er in die Kamera von
Skype so dass ich ihn mit meinem Handy
scannen kann ich sehe den QR-Code mein
Handy will ihn
scannen und fertig gescannt sein wir mal
großzügig und schicken ihm
5 ich schicke Jason
also 5 in Bitcoin gib Bescheid wenn dir
angezeigt wird dass du 5 in Bitcoin
bekommen
hast
fertig hat 10 15 Sekunden
gedauert Bitcoin ermöglicht es dem
Benutzer ohne dritt Partei sofort Geld
zu versenden oder zu
erhalten dieser digitale Meilenstein
macht den Benutzer quas
zuinenank
kom er neuen banklosen Währung ist
jedoch
gewaltig das macht 3240
Yen von der direkten Übergabe physischen
Geldes abgesehen sind wir bei Zahlungen
immer auf Drittparteien angewiesen
Kreditkarten internationale
Überweisungen sogar bei der Lagerung von
großen Summen nutzen wir Banken Bitcoin
ermögl es uns beiem auf die Parteien zu
verzichten wir sind unsere Bank unser
Zahlungssystem unser internationales
überweisungssystem wir können das alles
ohne Drittparteien leisten Bitcoin
macht's
[Musik]
möglich vor Bitcoin hatten alle diese
Firmen wie Paypal Visa und Bank of
America ein Hauptbuch mit allen
Kontoständen PayPal führt Buch darüber
wer genau wie viel Geld auf seinem
PayPal Konto hat das liegt dann auf dem
PayPal Server im PayPal
Rechenzentrum vor der Erfindung von
Bitcoin waren sich alle Mathematiker und
Computerwissenschaftler einig dass es
unmöglich wäre in einem dezentralen
Ledger die nötige Einigung zu erzielen
Bitcoin zeigte eine Möglichkeit auf so
einen Ledger zu führen und zu speichern
wer wie viele Bitcoins hat nur nicht in
einem Rechenzentrum sondern auf allen
Computern weltweit auf denen das Bitcoin
Netzwerk läuft auch mein Laptop hier
enthält eine komplette Kopie des Bitcoin
Ledgers
es ist dieser öffentliche Ledger die
blockchain die Bitcoin zur finanziellen
Revolution machen
könnte bitcoin ist eine kryptowährung
also eine digitale Währung bei der mit
Hilfe von
Verschlüsselungstechnologie die
Erstellung neuer Einheiten reguliert und
die Integrität von Geldtransfers
überprüft
wird neue Bitcoins werden durch einen
Vorgang namens mining erschaffen ein
meiner ist eine Person oder Gruppierung
die mit Hilfe leistungsstarker Computer
versucht komplexe mathematische Probleme
sogenannte Blocks zu lösen meiner auf
der ganzen Welt arbeiten um die Wette an
der Lösung dieses Blocks als Belohnung
erhalten Sie bei Erfolg frisch
erschaffene
Bitcoins alle Transaktionen über das
Bitcoin Netzwerk sind Teil dieses
komplexen mathematischen Puzzles bei der
Lösung dieses Puzzles überprüf die Meer
streng genommen die Integrität all
dieser
Transaktionen
hallo das hier war mal eine große
Recycling Anlage dort stehen noch zwei
Verbrennungsöfen bei dieser Wand liegen
sonarpanele mit Leistung
herum viel
also das deckt in etwa unseren
Verbrauch wir umgehen also sämtliche
Stromkosten es ist alles noch nicht
fertig eine Bitcoin Mine ist eine Gruppe
von Computern die ihre Rechenleistung
zur Abwicklung von Bitcoin Transfers und
für die Sicherheit des
es ist ein großer
Supercomputer all diese Computer
versuchen die Lösung des
mathematikproems zu
erraten es ist ein schwieriges Problem
bei dem sehr viele Computer raten müssen
liegt das richtige Ergebnis vor wird es
an alle anderen Computer geschickt und
alle Transaktionen bis zu diesem
Zeitpunkt
aufgezeichnet es ist ein sehr sicheres
System für die Erfassung und
Durchführung von Transaktionen keine
zwiichtig Geschichten passieren
können sonst kommt es bei Transaktionen
eventuell zu
Doppelbuchungen aber die blockchain
stellt sicher dass das nicht
passiert wenn eine Mail an Bob schicken
will muss diese Mail einen weiten Weg
durch das Netzwerk zurücklegen wird im
Hintergrund
kopiert und nicht nur
einmal die letzte Kopie am Ende
gelang zu
Bob so funktionieren E-Mails und
digitale Übertragungen und in den
meisten Fällen soll das auch so
sein schön und gut bei Geld hingegen
wäre es eine Katastrophe wenn es so
digital übertragen
würde es soll im Netzwerk schließlich
keine Kopien ein und derselben
Dollarnote geben das würde die begrenzte
Verfügbarkeit von Geld
ruinieren lö satosi nakamoto bei der
Erschaffung von
Bitcoin bei der Bitcoin blockchain wird
wenn z.B Bob einen Bitcoin schicken will
eine Transaktion erstellt und über das
Netzwerk
kopiert es unterscheidet sich aber von
einer einfachen E-Mail denn die
Transaktion enthält die Anweisung dass
von nun an Bob die Kontrolle über diesen
Bitcoin inne hat und das ganze Netzwerk
respektiert
das
mir wurde klar wie kompliziert Bitcoin
zu verstehen ist als ich einer Freundin
lang und breit Bitcoin
erklärte als ich nach Hause kam schrieb
sie mich auf Facebook an und war
verunsichert wegen Bitcoin ich hatte
mining erwähnt also wollte sie wissen ob
Bitcoins ursprünglich unter der Erde
lagen da wusste ich dass Bitcoin
schwierig zu verstehen ist mining ganz
besonders denn Bitcoins liegen nicht
unter der Erde
Bitcoin kann für Neulinge durchaus
schwierig zu verstehen sein Bitcoins
sind nicht physisch und ganz bestimmt
nicht unter der Erde es gibt jedoch
einige interessante Ähnlichkeiten
zwischen Bitcoin und einem edlen Metall
das man unter der Erde
findet Gold Gold dient seit jahusenden
als Geld und
Wertspeicher heute wird es auf
ab die Goldmenge die abgebaut werden
kann wird über den Lebenszyklus einer
Mine hinweg immer kleiner bis irgendwann
kein Gold mehr in der Mine gewonnen
werden
kann Bitcoin mining ist dahingehend
durchaus
ähnlich der Bitcoin Algorithmus ist so
programmiert dass die Belohnung für das
mining sich alle vier Jahre
halbiert bis im
jahr4 für abgeschlossen erklärt
wird vielleicht wollte der mysteriöse
Erschaffer von Bitcoin diese Eigenschaft
von Gold nachahen und eine digitale
Goldmünze erschaffen die aufgeteilt und
unmittelbar über die ganze Welt
verschickt werden
kann ich will es immer möglichst einfach
erklären Bitcoin meiner erhalten eine
Belohnung weil sie die Sicherheit von
Bitcoin
aufrechterhalten
mathematisch betrachtet lösen sie
schwierige Probleme es sind
schätzprozesse die Millionen von
Schätzungen
erfordern liegt man irgendwann richtig
und konnte alle Transaktionen in einem
Block abschließen erhält man als Miner
12,5
Bitcoins anfangs war die Belohnung 50
Bitcoins
alle vier Jahre halbiert sich diese
Belohnung für die meiner jedoch wodurch
sie immer kleiner
wird der Erfinder von Bitcoin wer auch
immer es sein mag war ein echt schlauer
Kerl an Mathematik hatte er
offensichtlich einen Narren gefressen
also setz er sich hin und rechnete durch
wie viele Bitcoins man brauchen würde
wenn alle Menschen Bitcoin nutzen
würden wie viele Bitcoin bräuchten wir
also wenn alle Bitcoin nutzen jeder
Bitcoin lässt sich in ein 100
Millionstel aufteilen würde die gesamte
Weltbevölkerung Bitcoin nutzen wäre
diese kleinste Einheit von Bitcoin ein
sogenannter Satoshi immer noch weniger
als einen uspenny Wert auch wenn die
ganze Welt Bitcoin
nutzt wer also ist Satoshi
nakamoto Z Jahre nach der
Veröffentlichung des White Papers für
das elektronische Peer topeer Cash
System verschwand die mysteriöse Gestalt
spurlos einzig das White Paper bietet
einige Hinweise auf ihre
Identität manche glauben die Figur wäre
britischer Herkunft der britische
Umgangssprache
vorkommt andere gehen davon aus dass
Satoshi nicht eine Einzelperson sondern
eine Gruppe von Hackern war die
gemeinsam an einem neuen dezentralen
Geldsystem arbeiteten
er war sicher ein schlauer Kerl nicht
einfach nur ein
GEK er kannte sich mit dezentraler
Technologie und Dezentralisierung
aus er kannte sich auch mit
Finanzsystemen
aus und er war ein ganz guter Coder auch
wenn der Code von Bitcoin nicht gerade
der beste
ist man könnte sicherlich einen besseren
Code schreiben
es wird auch gestritten ob der Bitcoin
Code von einer oder mehreren Personen
geschrieben
wurde schwer zu
sagen so oder so ist es vor allem die
erste funktionierende Implementierung
dezentralen
Geldes die Identität von satosi ist
schon sehr interessant gerade unter den
früheinsteigern von Bitcoin wird viel
spekuliert
aberentlich W B erschaffen
hat für mich macht es keinen Unterschied
wir wissen von vielen Dingen die wir
nutzen nicht wer sie erschaffen hat und
doch geben sie uns im Alltag viele
Vorteile ich hab keine Ahnung wer satosi
ist wir wissen fast nichts über satosi
könnte ein Ereignis sein eine
Bekanntschaft jemand mit dem ich mal
geredet habe oder ein Freund ich weiß es
nicht vielleicht erfahren wir es nie ich
find
lustig to
bin das beantworte ich
nicht wer auch immer Satoshi nakamuto
ist seine oder ihre Erfindung könnte die
zukünftige Entwicklung unserer Welt
maßgeblich
beeinflussen mit Bitcoin zahlen ist
cool es ist angesagt weil es die neueste
aktuellste Technologie
ist
damit Bitcoin jeder die Rolle seiner
eigenen Bank übernehmen kann entfallen
bisher übliche Hindernisse beim Zugriff
auf das eigene
Vermögen anders als bei Kreditkarten
üblich wo Zahlungen an unser Geschäft
gut und gerne 30 bis 60 Tage dauern
können kommen bitcoinzahlungen sofort
bei uns an das erleichtert uns die
Geschäftsführung
erheblich
[Musik]
wir alle nutzen Schlüssel im täglichen
Leben sie ermöglichen uns Verwaltung und
Kontrolle unseres wertvollen Eigentums
sie schützen zudem unsere
Wertgegenstände vor Diebstahl nehmen wir
das eigene Auto als Beispiel hat man den
Schlüssel kann man es nutzen wann immer
man will
wenn man aber mal einen über den Durst
getrunken hat weshalb einem ein
pflichtbewusster Freund den Schlüssel
wegnimmt gehört einem das Auto zwar
immer noch aber man hat keine Kontrolle
mehr darüber und muss anderweitig nach
Hause kommen das gleiche gilt für unsere
Finanzen wir haben unsere Bankkarte und
unseren Zugriffsschlüssel doch das Geld
befindet sich nicht direkt in unserem
Besitz wann immer wir etwas überweisen
oder von unserem Bankkonto abheben
handelt dieank
und überg das Geld für
uns Bit ist hierbei grundlegend
[Musik]
anders durch Bitcoin erhält man einen
ganz privaten Schlüssel zum eigenen
Vermögen bei Bein allen Werten der Welt
liegt die unmittelbare Verfügung und
Kontrolle dieser Werte nicht bei
uns Kontrolle über tausende Konten und
Geldautomaten niemand kam das ganze
Wochenende lang an sein Geld
ran wird eine Kredit oder Debitkarte
wegen Betrugsverdacht oder einer Buchung
an einem unerwarteten Ort gesperrt hält
die Kreditkartenfirma den Schlüssel in
der
Hand sie entscheiden nicht man
selbst bitin ist in der Hinsicht ganz
anders und basiert auf verschlüssel
entlich Schüssel man sendet also Bitcoin
an den öffentlichen
Schlüssel um die Sendung jedoch zu
starten muss man die Transaktion mit dem
privaten Schlüssel bei dem die Bitcoins
aktuell liegen
bestätigen dieser private Schlüssel ist
nichts anderes als eine
Zahl wenn man den privaten Schlüssel hat
kann man darauf
zugreifen Bitcoin Wallet ist ein
privater Schlüssel zugeordnet ein
privater Schlüssel der wie der Name
schon sagt den Zugang zum eigenen
Vermögen
entsperrt verliert man jedoch den
eigenen privaten Schlüssel kann man auch
sein Geld nicht mehr
[Musik]
zugreifen wir haben an einem Bitcoin
Geldautomaten Bitcoin gekauft und haben
eine codeall
erhalten ein Stück Papier mit zi
Quadraten wie be est unter denen ein
Haufen Buchstaben und Zahlen
stehen das obere ist der öffentliche
Schlüssel an den man Bitcoin senden
kann das untere ist der private
Schlüssel den man scannt um Bitcoin von
dieser Adresse
abzuheben den privaten Schlüssel sollte
man tunlichst nicht überall herum zeigen
denn wer ihn zuerst scannt kann alle
Bitcoins diese Adresse
abheben wenn man das Stück papierliert
man seine Bitcoins da niemand sonst eine
Kopie des privaten Schlüssels hat die
Adresse hier enthält tatsächlich
Bitcoins wir das hier also zum ersten
Mal sieht kann den Code scannen und die
Bitcoins
abheben das hier ist ein Satu coin
darin steckt ein Wert von
0,001
Bitcoin beim aktuellen Wechselkurs sind
das etwa 45
Cent also nicht viel aber es sind echte
Bitcoin
drin um den Wert der Münze einzulösen
muss man den hologrammsticker
abziehen hier
so dadurch kommt ein QRCode zum
Vorschein der ein privater Schlüssel ist
und quasi als Passwort
dient mit dem privaten Schlüssel und nur
damit kann man dann den Wert zu seiner
Bitcoin Wallet
hinzufügen
etwas physisches greifbares wirkt
authentischer um die Einstiegshürde von
Bitcoin möglichst niedrig zu halten war
es allen Beteiligten unseres Projekts
wichtig dass man einen greifbaren Teil
von Bitcoin bekommen
konnte ohne große
Kosten als unverbindlichen
Einstieg
da Bitcoin auf Verschlüsselung mit
öffentlichen und privaten Schlüsseln
basiert unterscheidet sich der Ablauf
des Zahlungsvorgangs besonders online
fundamental von
Kreditkarten Kreditkarten waren nie für
die Verwendung im Internet vorgesehen
bei ihrer Erfindung gab es kein
Internet bei einem pullsystem gibt man
Händlern die Berechtigung das Geld vom
Bankkonto einzuziehen wenn sie es für
wenn man mit Kreditkarte bezahlt gibt
man allen Händlern mit denen man handelt
effektiv den
Schlüssel bei jeder online Transaktion
geht man also ein Risiko ein da man den
Händlern diese empfindlichen
Informationen gibt mit denen Sie dann
auch selbst Transaktionen einleiten
können wenn Sie
wollen v
der Verbraucher hat viel größere
Kontrolle man schiebt das Geld zum
Empfänger wenn man beispielsweise bei
Internet Auftritten eine bitcoinadresse
mit ausstrahlt kann einem jeder Bitcoin
senden hat man als Band einen Auftritt
der auf der ganzen Welt ausgestrahlt
wird kann man auf der Bühne ein Schild
mit einer bitcoinadresse
aufstellen
dann kann jeder der das Konzert ansieht
einen Bitcoins schicken wann auch immer
man es
[Musik]
ansieht ich bin saniro fujimuto ich
spiele Saxophon und andere
Instrumente ich schreibe Lieder trete
auf und mache CDs so verdiene ich mein
Geld als
Musiker
die kleine livhow heute koste keinen
Eintritt wenn einem meine Musik gefällt
kann man mir ein Trinkgeld
[Musik]
geben bei Trinkgeldern weiß man nie wie
viel man bekommt man könnte nichts
bekommen oder wenn der Auftritt gut ist
auch mehr als man
erwartet das hilft mir besser zu spielen
[Applaus]
bei der direkten Interaktion geht es
mehr um die Kunst an
sich gibt man auf der Straße ein
Trinkgeld gibt man nicht viel Geld
sentbeträge Kleingeld
eben Geld über das Internet zu versenden
kostet mehr als man als Trinkgeld geben
soll darum ist Bitcoin viel besser dafür
geeignet ein Trinkgeld über das Internet
zu
[Musik]
geben bitcoinzahlungen nutzen ein
pushsystem das Geld wird vom Absender
zum Empfänger geschoben dies ist
schneller und billiger als traditionelle
pullsysteme wie bei
Kreditkartentransaktionen zudem sind
Bitcoin Transaktionen dadurch endgültig
und
unumkehrbar
Kreditkartenzahlungen dauern tatsächlich
6 Monate auch wenn die Zahlung scheinbar
durch ist kann man sie noch
zurückfordern und sie als Betrug
bezeichnen dann nimmt die
Kreditkartenfirma dem Händler das Geld
wieder weg manchmal übernimmt sie auch
selbst die Kosten das sind
Rückbelastungen die durch die
dre%ozentige Gebühr auf
Kreditkartenzahlungen abgedeckt werden
die of der Händler
übernimmt Aktionen gibt es keine
Rückbelastung für mich ist das etwas
Gutes man hört zwar oft die
Anfechtbarkeit wäre etwas Gutes aber es
kommt nur selten dazu wenn man bei
seriösen Firmen bestellt und nicht
zufrieden ist löst die Firma fast immer
das
Problem zu Rückbelastungen kommt es fast
nur wenn die Kreditkarte gestohlen wird
und das kann immer
passieren alle Kreditkarten sind im
Internet es ist einfach nur Pech wenn
die eigene Karte für Betrug verwendet
wird es gibt hier einige Unternehmen die
Bitcoin akzeptieren hier in acapulko vor
allem
Restaurants wenn Händler Bitcoin
annehmen ist das eine zweite innovative
Option für Sie es bietet Ihnen viele
Vorteile wir erheben keine Gebühren
anders als Kreditkartenfirmen die bis zu
10% jeder Transaktion
behalten bei uns ist das gratis es gibt
keinen
Mindestbetrag man kann auch nur 10 15
Pesos bezahlen wenn man
will da Bitcoin Zahlungen die
Geschäftskosten verringern und
betrügerische Transaktionen verhindern
Nutzen mehr und mehr Firmen vom Tante
Emma Laden bis zum multinationalen
Konzern diese neue Art des
wirerttransfers
das ist aus Harvard und das ist mein
Harvard
Stuhl den Stuhl habe ich 1977 bis 99
bekommen ich nutze immer noch
Faxe aber da wir jetzt auch Facebook und
SMS haben können wir Bilder einfacher
verschicken z.B Passfotos wenn wir
verreisen in Zukunft wird es keine Faxe
mehr geben
ähnlich sieht es für die Zukunft von
Kreditkarten und Geld
aus ich glaube virtuelles Geld wird eine
große Rolle
spielen in Anbetracht dieser Aussichten
will ich mich international aufstellen
und bei der Verwendung dieser virtuellen
Währung im zahnmedizinischen Bereich
vorne mit dabei
sein mein Geschäft soll gemeinsam mit
der Popularität von Bitcoin
wachsen
overstock war die erste große
börsennotierte Firma die Bitcoin annahm
sie verschicken ihre waren jetzt in über
200 Länder Amazon soweit ich weiß nur in
50 oder 60 Länder sie bedienen Märkte
mit Milliarden von Menschen und müssen
sich ihren Marktanteil dort nicht einmal
erkämpfen wenn Amazon Bitcoin
akzeptieren würde gebe es dort keinen
Betrug mehr keine Rückbelastungen und
die Kosten würden sinken Amazons
Gewinnmarge würde durch die Annahme von
Bitcoin deutlich
steigen Bitcoin ermöglicht es Händlern
Bezahlungen für Waren und
Dienstleistungen problemlos anzunehmen
wenngleich es ein großartiger Weg für
Händler ist ihr Angebot in bisher
unerschlossene Märkte auszuweiten sind
es die Menschen in diesen
Schwellenländern die am meisten
profitieren bitcoin ist die einfachste
sicherste schnell
und beste Option für Menschen ohne
Bankkonto ohne Ausweis die nur ein
Smartphone haben viele Menschen befinden
sich in so einer Lage bitcoin ist für
sie eine fantastische Möglichkeit an der
Weltwirtschaft teilzunehmen ohne sich
mit Banken herumschlagen und ihre
Spielchen mitmachen zu müssen sie
installieren eine App und schon sind sie
Teil der
Weltwirtschaft ungefähr ein Drittel der
kreditkartenansaktionen aus
Afrika trug betroffen also will niemand
mit Afrika Handeln zu
riskant bei Bitcoin weiß man dass die
Zahlung stimmt also verkauft man als
Händler doch gerne alles mögliche sofern
es in Afrika legal ist und dann kommt
das Eigentumsrecht ins
Spiel das Eigentumsrecht wird Ihnen dann
helfen aus der Armut
auszubrechen Bitcoin schließt die Lücke
im Bankbereich für Menschen ohne Konto
in Entwicklungsländern haben viele kein
Bankkonto noch nicht einmal Ausweise um
ein Konto zu
eröffnen wenn sie aber Handys und
Internetzugang haben kann ihr Handy für
Sie zur Bank
werden Statistiken der Weltbank zufolge
gibt es in Entwicklungsländern knapp 2
Milliarden Menschen ohne
Bankkonto
dieung länd könte dieses
menschenrechtsproblem wandeln und der
kontolosen Bevölkerung die Teilhabe an
der Weltwirtschaft
ermöglichen zum ersten Mal in der
Weltgeschichte kann jeder jeden
beliebigen Geldbetrag versenden oder
erhalten mit jedem Partner überall
sofort nahezu kostenlos und ohne das
andere einschließlich Regierungen es
verhindern
können so sehr ich Gold auch Liebe das
kann es
nicht es ist kaum vorstellbar jeder hier
kann jetzt den Geldbetrag überall hin an
jeden versenden sofort und niemand kann
etwas tun um es aufzuhalten das war vor
Bitcoin einfach nicht möglich weshalb es
eine revolutionäre Technologie für alle
Menschen der Welt
ist wikaks konnte sich durch Bitcoin
finanzieren das warchem die finanzre gen
wikileak verhängt
hatte VISA Mastercard und die Bank of
America dürften keine Spenden an
Wikileaks weitergeben
egal was man von Wikileaks
hält ich persönlich bin nicht mit all
ihren Aktionen
einverstanden aber für die Freiheit der
Welt ist es unabdingbar dass die
Möglichkeit Spenden zu übergeben nicht
zensiert werden kann egal für
welchetischen z Spenden das Wikileaks
den USA so trotzen konnte war eine
bedeutende
Botschaft da bei Bitcoin der private
Schlüssel des Vermögens allein beim
Benutzer liegt kann man damit Aktivismus
finanzieren ebenso kann man aber mit
Bitcoin auch das Nachtleben
genießen mein
Name und ichin ein deranis tok Bitcoin
Meetup
[Applaus]
Group heute haben wir ein Event mitlesk
Tänzerinnen die ihr Trinkgeld in Bitcoin
bekommen wir machen so etwas ab und zu
damit unsere Zusammenkünfte interessant
bleiben und wir nicht immer nur über die
technischen Feinheiten und Politik
diskutieren das ist also ein spaßiges
Event bei dem wir zeigen was mit
böglich
derzeit ist es in den meisten Ländern
kein Problem Dinge zu kaufen man hat
Kreditkarten und kann Bargeld nutzen
hier liegt nicht der wahre Zweck von
Bitcoin der wahre Zweck von bitcoin ist
finanzielle Privatsphäre was mir sehr
wichtig
ist als ich während der Krise Risse im
Gefüge des Finanzsystems zeigten
erschienen Institutionen die einst als
unverwundbar galten plötzlich
angreifbar heute wissen wir dass sich
Regierungen auf der ganzen Welt
gezwungen sahen Banken zu
retten bei einem solchen Bailout
verwendet die Regierung Steuergelder um
unverantwortlich handelnde
Finanzinstitutionen vor den Konsequenzen
ihrer Fehler zu
schützen bei einem bailin hingegen
werden Gesetze erlassen die es Banken
erlauben das Geld direkt aus den Konten
ihrer Anleger einzuziehen um Verluste zu
kompensieren dies geschah 2013 auf
zyper als ich mich 2013 über Bitcoin
schlau machte wurden in Zypern gerade
Banken geschlossen und das Geld der
Menschen
konfisziert ich sprach mit Kollegen
studierten hochintelligenten Menschen
darüber wie schlimm das doch sei und
dass das nun auch anderen westlichen
Ländern
drohte sie lachten und sagten es wäre
doch nur Zypern das könnte hier niemals
geschehen da wurde mir klar dass eine
Möglichkeit her musste das Problem zu
umgehen wenn jemand Dollar oder Euro in
eine Bank einzahlt gehen diese Dollar
oder Euro in den Besitz der Bank
über wenn die Banken dann große Fehler
machen haben sie nun in vielen Ländern
das Recht der Gläubigerbeteiligung
bekommen bei dem sie das Geld ihrer
Anleger in Anteile an der Bank umwandeln
können jeff perck ist Unternehmer
wirtschaftskommentator und podcas
Host die Analysen Videos und Essays des
Gründers von
stockhuse.com der größten Website für
Finanznachrichten in Kanada erreichten
weltweit Millionen von Menschen
die Zukunft genau vorherzusagen ist
schwierig aber was in Zypern passierte
wird wieder geschehen so war es in
Griechenland wo die Banken geschlossen
wurden am 1 januar 2016 wurde das
europäische bankenrettungsgesetz
erlassen was Europäer besonders
interessieren sollte das sollte viele
alarmieren in Zypern wurden sogar die
Banken zuerst geschlossen und erst
danach Gesetze erlassen durch die die
Banken das Geld ihrer Kunden behalten
konnten um sich über Wasser zu halten in
Zypern hatte man also noch keine
rechtliche Grundlage jetzt aber schon es
ist also klar was
passiert ich sehe Bitcoin als eine
Möglichkeit das eigene Vermögen zu
schützen und zu
verbergen das ist nichts
Schlechtes nicht nur Verbrecher
verstecken ihr
Vermögen man hat hart gearbeitet und
Steuern
gezahlt und muss dann mit ansehen
Griechenland und Zypern einfach das Geld
der Bankkonten konfisziert
wird wenn das nächste Mal also Banken in
Schwierigkeiten geraten werden womöglich
die Konten der Kunden geplündert um das
Banksystem zu
finanzieren es trifft Menschen die viel
Geld haben 100tausende Euro aber sie
haben sich das Geld ehrlich
erarbeitet manche Ökonomen sehen die
Wirtschaftskrise der nuller Jahre nur
als Vorboten einer erheblich größeren
Katastrophe wie werden Regierungen also
auf den nächsten Zusammenbruch unseres
Finanzsystems reagieren wenn es dazu
kommt anders als im herkömmlichen
Banksystem gibt Bitcoin dem einzelnen
den privaten Schlüssel zu seinem
Vermögen selbst in die Hand man ist
dadurch jedoch auch selbst dafür
verantwortlich seine Bitcoins zu
sichern ige Kontrolle über sein Geld
aber eben auch die volle Verantwortung
für sein Geld man muss also selbst für
die Sicherheit
sorgen man ist Kreditkarten Bankkonten
und Paypal gewohnt wenn die Kreditkarte
gestohlen wird ruft man die
Kreditkartenfirma an sperrt die Karte
und das war's wenn einem Bitcoins
gestohlen werden kann einem niemand
dabei
helfen andererseits muss man auch
niemanden um Erlaubnis bitten um seine
Bitcoins nach gut dünken zu verwenden
ein zweischneidiges
Schwert die tokoter bitcoinbörse Mount
Gos hat Insolvenz angemeldet wenige Tage
zuvor wurde bekannt dass der Firma
Bitcoins im Wert von 415 Millionen
Dollar abhanden gekommen waren CEO Mark
entschuldigte sich im japanischen
Fernsehen mit einer tiefen Verbeugung
doch es bleibt unklar ob die fehlenden
Bitcoins gestohlen oder durch technische
Fehler ungültig
wurden
das ist das ehemalige Gebäude von Mount
go Mount go war die größte bitcoinbörse
aller Zeiten sie erreicht ein
Handelsvolumen von über 100 Millionen
Dollar am Tag 2014 ging die Firma
spektakulär
unter die Verluste summierten sich auf
über 450 Millionen
Dollar angeblich verloren sie
bitcoon wiedergefunden
wurden ihre Kunden gaben ihnen ihr Geld
ihre Bitcoins und sie gaben ihnen
Kontrolle über ihre privaten Schlüssel
obwohl Bitcoin ja gerade vor diesem
Risiko der Zentralisierung schützen
soll Mount gox entfernte also die ganze
Dezentralisierung von Bitcoin lagerte
das Geld vieler Leute in einer Firma und
überließ die Kontrolle über all dieses
Geld einer Person die quasi den
Schlüssel zum Reich
hatte in den letzten Jahren konnten wir
beobachten wie es in verschiedenen
Fällen ich glaube in mindestens 10 dazu
kam dass Bitcoin Firmen Opfer großer
Hackerangriffe
wurden man darf nicht vergessen dass
Bitcoin sich anders verhält als die
Verwahrung eines Werts im normalen
Finanzwesen bei Bitcoin kann man wenn
man den privaten Schlüssel einer
außerhalb der firmeninfrastruktur eine
Transaktion einleiten ohne dass sie
etwas davon
mitbekommen das gibt es sonst nirgends
im Finanzbereich wo man die
Infrastruktur der Institution erst
unterwandern muss um Geld zu
entwenden uns allen wurde beigebracht
dass wir unser Geld nicht selbst
verwalten können also geben wir es
Banken zur
Verwahrung die Geisteshaltung dass wir
unser Geld in einer Institution bündeln
sollten deren einziger Zweck in der
Verwahrung besteht werden wir nur
schwerlich abschütteln oder ändern
können das ist wohl die größte
Herausforderung für
Bitcoin man muss diese Konvention in
Frage stellen die Kontrolle über das
eigene Geld und das eigene Vermögen
übernehmen und es dann selbst
schützen aktuell ist Bitcoin sehr sicher
man bräuchte die halbe Rechenleistung
des ganzen Bitcoin Netzwerks um die
Kontrolle darüber zu
übernehmen das ist technisch gesehen
wirklich schwer in Anbetracht der
aktuellen Rechenleistung des Bitcoin
Netzwerks nahezu
unmöglich so gesehen ist Bitcoin also
viel sicherer als selbst die größten und
sichersten Portale einiger der größten
Banken der
Welt viele Menschen vertrauen Bitcoin
aber nicht einfach weil man in den
Nachrichten oft von Hackerangriffen auf
Bitcoin Portale und einige Börsen
hört aber
eigentlich sind alle Bitcoin Dienste gar
nicht Bitcoin an
sich man sollte also nicht die
Sicherheit Bitcoin basierter Dienste mit
der Sicherheit von Bitcoin an sich
verwechseln
der Zusammenbruch der bitcoinbörse Mount
Gos im Jahr 2014 brachte große
Verunsicherung und Skepsis bezüglich der
Sicherheit von Bitcoin hervor dennoch
Jahre nach dem Absturz der ein größten
bitcoinbörse der Welt interessieren sich
immer mehr Institutionen innerhalb der
Finanzindustrie für
Bitcoin die große Frage war für
viele
Technologie einen Einfluss auf die
Finanzbranche haben
würde heute fragt auf Branchenmessen
niemand mehr ob sondern nur noch wie die
blockchain die Finanzbranche verändern
und transformieren
wird das blockchain Technologie die
Finanzbranche verändern wird steht außer
Frage das ist die aktuelle Lage das war
aber nicht immer
so noch vor Jahren galt Bitcoin noch als
lächerliche Idee die sich niemals
langfristig etablieren könnte und keine
Anwendung im Finanzwesen finden
würde das japanische Unterhaus hat die
Gesetzgebung zu virtuellen Währungen
beschlossen und wir hoffen dass auch das
Oberhaus sie demnächst
bestätigt somit würde die Regierung die
Existenz virtueller Währungen anerkennen
Regulierungen implementieren und die
Branche
[Musik]
unterstützen der Bitcoin hier sieht eben
hübsch
aus ein schönes
Souvenir besser als ein oder
[Musik]
zu den Gebieten in denen sich Bitcoin
besonders durchsetzen konnte zählt China
wegen der ganzen Kapitalkontrollen und
ähnliche Länder wie Argentinien und Iran
dort konnten sich viele für Bitcoin
begeistern da man sonst ohne Probleme
mit Regulierungen zu bekommen oder die
richtigen Kontakte in der Regierung zu
haben nur schwer Geld über die
Landesgrenze bekommt da gibt Bitcoin MIV
[Musik]
aufgrund seiner Vorzüge gewinnt Bitcoin
auf der ganzen Welt weiterhin an
Popularität auch an den
unwahrscheinlichsten
Orten ich bin David und betreibe das
caff Phoenix rising in
nimin das ist unser Bitcoin
Geldautomat direkt neben dem normalen
Geldautomaten die Kunden haben die freie
Wahl
ich empfand das aktuelle Banksystem als
ziemlich restriktiv und die Vorstellung
dass der Einzelne sein eigenes
Banksystem betreiben könnte faszinierte
mich außerdem ist es digital und wir
leben im digitalen Zeitalter es war also
klar dass es an Fahrt aufnehmen
würde bitcoin ist sicherlich die größte
Revolution der Finanzwissenschaft seit
Isaac Newtons
Goldstandard
es wird völlig verändern wie wir unser
Vermögen lagern und
verwalten es wird das Recht die
Buchhaltung die Finanzbranche und so
viel mehr
verändern und es wird das Kapital sehr
schnell
dezentralisieren es werden nicht mehr
Millionen von Menschen ihr Kapital auf
einem haufenlagern über den dann ein
Vorständler von Mar lych oder der Bank
of America
entscheidet man wird dann Millionen von
Einzelpersonen überzeugen müssen ihr
Vermögen für einen Krieg im Irak oder in
Afghanistan zur Verfügung zu
stellen wenn es keinen zentralen
Schlüssel zum Vermögen der vielen mehr
gibt wde schwieriger die Menschen davon
zu überzeugen für Güter und
Dienstleistungen zu bezahlen die Sie
nicht
wollen ich scanne es und se hier ade in
meiner Wallet ich gebe einen Dollar ein
drücke auf Senden es
sendet gesendet da ist es das war der
Ton vor Bitcoin war ich quasi im
Ruhestand genoss mein Leben machte jeden
tagitu ich hatte echt Spaß aber es half
nicht wirklich die Welt zu einem
besseren Ort zu machen wenn
überhaupt dann entdeckte ich Bitcoin ich
s wie auf der Welt Kriege geführt werden
Zentralbanken Währungen entwerten und
das all dies verhindert dass die Welt so
gut wird wie sie sein
kann ich erkannte also in Bitcoin ein
Werkzeug ihnen allen die Macht dazu zu
geben die meisten wollen nicht dafür
bezahlen Menschen in fremden Ländern zu
töten allerdings für Schulen Straßen und
Krankenhäuser wenn die Regierung also
Geld für Straßen Schulen Krankenhäuser
braucht bekommt sie das wahrscheinlich
wenn die Regierung sagt sie braucht men
l töten die man wahscheinlich nie zu
Gesicht bekommen
wird dafür will keiner zahlen wenn man
aber Bankkonten Dollar und Euro nutzt
kann die Regierung jederzeit das
Bankkonto beschlagnahmen endlos Dollar
und Euro drucken um für alles zu
bezahlen nutzt die Welt Bitcoin
entfallen diese Werkzeuge und die Welt
wird zu einem viel besseren
Ort zum ersten Mal in der
Menschheitsgeschichte
B ein
vollständigzentrales Zahlungssystem zur
Verfügung es gibt im Einzelnen die
tatsächliche Kontrolle über sein
finanzielles
vermögen es erlaubt allen Benutzern die
Übertragung von Werten und die freie
unmittelbare Interaktion
miteinander wie könnte die Zukunft der
Welt mit so einem revolutionären
Werkzeug aussehen die Möglichkeiten
erscheinen nahezu wie
Magie
bitcoin ist magisches
internetgeld mit Bitcoin kann man mit
jedem überall auf der Welt Geld
austauschen es ist wie
Magie ich kann meine Begeisterung und
die Bedeutsamkeit nicht in Worte
fassen mit Bitcoin nimmt man einfach
sein Smartphone installiert eine App und
kann ih nur 30 Sekunden mit allen
Menschen überall auf der Welt Geld
austauschen effektiv
umsonst n Jahre oder 100 Jahre alt ist
egal in welchem Land auf der Welt das
ist
[Musik]
Magie